Hugh Jackman you're you're back being
Wolverine so presumably that means
[Applause]
I decided you are back that is the
blueprint for actors like when we saw
this every actor wanted to mimic what he
did and listening to his diet and his
workout regimen that this is the blue
this is
[Laughter]
sugar right before you shoot you know
what I'm saying I'm gonna be hydrating
yourself yeah that's where I got it from
really cool wow yeah but I wasn't
directing at the same time
but uh I mean so obviously there's a lot
of gym work but the diet is even worse
in a way that's the thing I didn't
realize uh bodybuilders will always say
their body is 70 their diet and only 30
they're training because I assumed it
was all about Pumping Iron but it's a
science the whole eating thing is a
science and I complain about it all day
long I'm in this thing right now where
I'm eating 5 000 calories a day I'm just
loading eating eating and I'm
complaining my wife's like shut up
um but yeah sitting beside these two
guys I feel like they're a tuxedo and
I'm a pair of brown shoes
hahaha
oh yeah thank you brown shoes
[Applause]
famous George Goebel line but yeah I'm
gonna tell you I told my daughter that I
was on the show with him and she said
will you get him to say my two left feet
line just when you said shoes and I just
thought it's one of the greatest lines
in movies from do you remember It Best
in Show Best in Show uh I can't dance
I've got two left feet
yeah
that's a great dad great day yeah good
job
[Music]